genius comes in many different forms and
the best kind makes our lives easy to
appreciate that kind of functional
creativity i found some amazing tools
that are on another level this is not a
drill join me as i take you through
these tools and tell you why i found
them to be on another level mini water
tap turbine starting us off is jasper
pew's mini water tap turbine have you
ever used a tap with low water pressure
well this 3d printed mini tap turbine
whose design was based on a cross flow
turbine is the solution to that problem
its function is to improve low water
pressure in taps by concentrating the
flow of water and releasing it as a
faster stream to use it attach it to the
mouth of the tap and as the turbine
spins the water pressure improves if
water pressure has never been a problem
in your area then this is a great tool
to have in your travel bag just in case
your travel destination's water pressure
needs a little extra help chopper one
axe
you better be ready for another
exceptionally functional axe because it
exists the chopper one axe helps you
easily split the wood with every strike
its specially engineered axe head has
rotating levels that use the energy
exerted when striking the wood to push
outwards ensuring that it splits down
the middle every time unlike a regular
rax with this one the probability of
hitting the same spot multiple times to
get a thick log to split is
significantly reduced it's a great tool
to show off and earn survival skill
points even if you're a first timer
reaper wheels
speaking of travelling next we have the
reaper wheels these wheels are on a
totally different level and will
transform your normal ice buggy into a
death trap and something from a horror
movie the reaper wheels allow you to
travel on ice without slipping like
ordinary wheels these wheels are made
entirely out of metal spikes that are
supposed to give the ice buggy a better
grip on ice not sure how many people
would want to transform their vehicles
like this so it's a good thing they're
removable one thing is for sure though
if i ever visit antarctica these are
coming with me efox professional
cordless tile beater from the wheels of
death to a more practical tool the efox
professional cordless vibrator tile
beater is a tool used to eliminate air
bubbles that may be trapped below tile
slabs once installed why do we need it
you may ask well if bubbles aren't
removed when the adhesive sets the air
will create a vacuum that may cause
cracks in the future now that we've
established its importance let's take a
closer look at the tool itself the efox
professional cordless vibrator tile
beater has multiple handles and an
adjustable vibrating area to cater to
both big and small surfaces on a single
charge the battery can work on 150 to
200 square meters and has a guaranteed
battery life of up to 100 000 square
meters now that's a lot of safe tiles
brush grubber extreme
moving along next is the brush grubber
extreme tool using its tooth claws the
brush grubber extreme tool easily pulls
shallow rooted trees up to six inches in
diameter from the ground to eliminate
regrowth it has two large total gripping
teeth per pad and spring-loaded jaws to
ensure a strong and secure hole the jaws
open wide to handle bigger trees and the
grip pads rotate 360 degrees to help
avoid debarking this powerful tool can
be operated by one person it can attach
to any atv pickup or lawn tractor to
provide the pulling force the brush
grubber extreme tool has surely taken
de-rooting trees to another level and
made it any man's sport timber croc log
holder the timber croc log holder as the
name suggests safely and securely holds
logs pallets and planks while they are
being cut using its patented teeth
design it was invented designed and
manufactured in ireland timber croc log
holder's design was copyright approved
and patent protected as the original
timber croc this tool holds a log
without any other support and its
heavy-duty version can grip logs
exceeding 20 kilograms both eliminate
many of the dangers traditionally
associated with log cutting and make log
cutting a job for one person as if
that's not enough it also stands higher
off the ground with enough clearance to
wheel a small trailer underneath that
will catch the falling logs if you ask
me this is a very convenient and
efficient game changer for log cutters
the multifunctional hammer
next we get into the realm of
multi-functionality this tool would make
the ordinary toolbox lonely if it were
to replace some of the tools the
multifunctional hammer is designed to
serve as a hammer power nail gun nail
puller pipe plier wrench screwdriver
clamps pincers vise and spanner weighing
600 grams this stainless steel tool's
multiple functionalities are adjustable
to be able to work on varying materials
and sizes because of its various and
wide application it is suitable for
house furniture repair outdoor camping
factory processing and everything in
between the multifunctional ratchet w
with 180 degrees rotating head still on
multifunctional tools i found another
amazing tool the multifunctional ratchet
w with 180 degrees rotating head it
comes in two sizes the 10 inch and the 8
inch the 10 inch wrench is 260
millimeters long and can reach a maximum
opening of 32 millimeters while the 8
inch wrench has a maximum opening of 24
millimeters at 204 millimeters long it's
made of steel and can be folded up to
allow for work in hard to reach places
the ratchet's fixed mode has a
tightening feature that can be adjusted
continuously while in use and it has a
handy magic button that switches the
ratchet on and off to use it as a
ratchet wrench or a traditional wrench
pivot ladder tool
from multi-functionality to simple
functionality we move on to the
provision tools pivot ladder tool the
pivot ladder tool is the ultimate ladder
accessory it gives a stable platform for
most ladders and works well on uneven
ground making ladder use safer this tool
requires no bolts or clamps and moving
from one ladder to another requires no
special equipment it can be used as a
ladder jack indoors and out on rooftops
and stairs as well as a mini shelf for
your tools when attached to the ladder
with hundreds of rubber gripper feet
made from rugged conveyor belt material
the pivot tool will keep the ladder from
slipping since we will all have to
change a bulb at some point or another
this is a great tool to have kexel
montelet mosaic glass and tile nippers
another amazing tool i found is the
kexel montelet mosaic glass and tile
nippers the italian company montelet
took the wheeled nipper to a whole new
level these professional level wheel
nippers are tough enough to shape marble
and porcelain yet gentle enough for
glass the entire tool is made of steel
tungsten and titanium pretty strong
materials so you know they're tough the
nippers have smaller angled wheels for
greater material access and straight cut
the handles are a bit longer at 10
inches to give that little extra
leverage needed when cutting harder
materials this one could be reserved for
the professionals but it does belong
here casper hamilton core axe this next
tool is a classic example of functional
creativity imagine having an axe with
interchangeable heads while you imagine
that casper hamilton has already gone
ahead and made the casper hamilton corex
this tool package consists of a health
and two interchangeable heads its
straight shaft health is made from a
carbon fiber and ashwood sandwich to pay
homage to the heritage of a traditional
axe the two heads are a 1200 gm felling
head and a 1 500 gm splitting head both
made out of reheated carbon steel the
weight of the axe is therefore focused
at the head giving greater striking
momentum and efficiency when cutting or
splitting wood each head is specially
designed to be optimal for its own
different functions this one seems like
the perfect companion for outdoors men
and women paint hedging tool
the next tool will change how you feel
about painting edges the paint edging
tool quickly and meticulously paints
edges around baseboards window trims
doors and ceilings without the mess the
tool has a hollow handle that holds
almost five ounces of paint all you need
to do is slowly press the trigger to
feed paint directly to the paint pad
when painting the pad soaks up the paint
evenly to give off consistent paint any
remaining paint can be squeezed back
into the can which is also very
economical if you want to go pro next
time you have a diy paint project this
is the perfect tool and when you're done
with it it is easily cleaned by rinsing
the tool in and out using water or any
cleaning liquid if you enjoyed this
video hit the subscribe button and
continue watching by clicking on one of
the cards on your screen see you at the
next one